foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
I do recommend Meetup to a lot of my
friends that are looking for different
things wine tasting movies book clubs
meet a lot of new people a lot of new
friends and it make you more social
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
what is a chess Dynasty
unceasing dominance move after move
again and again and again we have a
recitation we have history he is the
five-time fide World chess champion
but a chess Dynasty can also be cruel it
forces most to defer their dreams until
next time if there is a next time oh my
god did he just block yeah he did I'm
Blown Away the game is over
as the Chess World Turns to Kazakhstan
the Magnus Carlson Dynasty is set to
close
the feed a world championship is finally
up for grabs
for two chess Superstars lying in weight
until next time is now
Jan napam Nashi has methodically done
what he needed to do to get another shot
at the title the pressure to seize the
moment this time rests heavily upon Him
saves the game with the black pieces
which means that he is one game closer
to the world championship title
dingley Ren knows firsthand what the end
of this dynasty means an unexpected
chance to make history
can China's best turn his Good Fortune
into Eternal Fame The Rook Pawn is going
to be a draw and being there with a
smile gives it up he knows there's no
trying in this one hard what happened
the legacy of this Championship spans
across centuries it reads from the names
of Chess Giants
for the first time in a decade a new
name will raise the trophy and be etched
into chess history
it's the 2023 feed a world championship
whose name will next be called champion
foreign
chest fever is on in Astana as the city
hosts the ultimate battle to Crown the
king of classical chess it's been a long
journey for the two Challengers to the
halls of the Saint Regis Hotel and we
are live inside the playing Arena as we
wait for Yana Pam Nashi and then learn
to arrive it's now the final stretch of
the video world championship match
welcome everyone I'm International
Master Tanya suchdev alongside me my
co-commentators Grandmaster Robert Hess
and a Grandmaster Fabiano caruana four
games remain
leads with one point thing Lauren has to
strike back to equalize right off the
bat Fabi what's the one thing you're
expecting from ding today
I don't know if it's so much expecting
but I think that he is in a position now
when we're getting close to the end of
the match when maybe it's time to take
some extra risks and we've seen these
players both take risks during these
matches during this match but in the
last few games they've played rather
quietly steadily but ding is still down
a point and he doesn't want to let it
get to that you know final few games
when he's in a must-win situation I
think he should try to take the chance
now to get some chances
as we get closer to the Finish Line in a
14-game match each match becomes that
much heavier the pressure increases the
margin for error at this point for ding
lyron is zero he needs to win a game
looking good with every passing game he
gets closer to becoming world champion
Robert what will Beyond's approach today
well you say the margin for error for
dingly rent is nearly zero the number of
Errors yesterday was pretty much zero
and for Yonder Palm she I think it's
gonna be more of the same why should he
take any risk why does he need to do
anything different he should play his
solid steady approach another draw will
not be a bad result from especially
because there's a rest day tomorrow and
then he can prepare to have the black
pieces in the 12th round
a draw in this match would mean that Ian
just goes steps closer to that world
championship title while for ding it
would mean one game less to strike back
so much at stake the start of the world
championship match this first half was a
fist fight with five decisive games
starting from a game two and then we saw
four back-to-back victories with the
white pieces but going into the second
half we see the players treading more
cautiously they are taking less risks
and playing with incredibly high
accuracy as we saw starting from game
eight it was a draw 3 back to back draws
in game 10 once again with the white
pieces we saw Tingler and push exert
pressure but Ian had a principal
approach to defense and though ding
tried Fabi it was never close to being
enough
yeah we yesterday we saw a nearly
perfect one could even say perfect game
of chess but at the moment ding doesn't
want perfect games or chess he wants a
mess he wants some blood as tell said
you want to take your opponent into a
deep dark forest and that's what ding
needs at the moment he really needs to
get back into into the equality of the
match and then you know what we'll see
in the final few games but I think it
would be very difficult for him if we're
going to the final game of the match and
he needs to win you know white pieces or
not you you don't have
amazing chances of winning a single game
against a player as strong and as well
prepared as young and probably she's so
every game is a chance I think he should
try be trying to create complications
and you know a way for his opponent to
make mistakes yeah I think for ding he
needs to make the most of his chances
but he's just not going to get them I'm
sorry to say I know Chad's going to hate
me but I expect a d word a draw today I
think that's what is likely because
yonda palmchi he wants to Coast through
to the Finish Line he sees it it's
within his sight so why should he take
any risk he has the white pieces if he
can liquidate if he can make a draw I
think he's gonna do that
will he be under pressure one more time
with the black pieces and will he be
able to hold for it it was a confident
hold in a game plan by Jan napomnushi
and this is what ding had to say about
the outcome of the game
today I drew another white game
so it means
there are only four games left
I need to at least
[Music]
the score it's become quite normal like
there are three draws
in the three drones and okay there the
tournaments do not finish yet
so okay we still have four games left I
wouldn't say I was how much confidence
am I now I didn't consider that
four games left two with with the white
pieces for dangler and confidence will
be a big factor in this one and as we
can see our chesscom stats team has
given these odds based on the outcome
the result of today's game 11. it's
going to be a big exciting day of chess
if Jana Palmer she with the white pieces
wins essentially it won't just be game
over it will be match over it's nearly
impossible tingling will need the
biggest of Miracles to come back from a
two-point deficit a 98 favorite for
yandere with a draw still more than an
80 favorite and if thing strikes back
with the black pieces our stats team
actually edges inches more towards ding
with a 47 to Yana pamushi looking at
these stats Robert is it fair to say
that for ding it's more important to
keep things under control to not take
extra risk than to try for a win today
with black yeah for a dingley ren he
gets two whites in the remaining three
games after today we've seen him create
Chances with the white pieces not
yesterday but in game eight that results
may have been a draw but he was winning
so as you said confidence will be
important for him I think he should
confidently try to neutralize the
opening advantage today and then he
could take it from there
easier said than done Robin
she's starting with a white piece
come down to what is Yan's approach
today will he be the one who tried to
close off the match today maximize his
chances try to create Chaos on the board
but the drawback of that strategy would
be that Ding perhaps could get his
moments in the game and Strike Back well
it's been a fascinating World
Championship with so many decisive games
with the black pieces we've seen only
one win so far and it was back in game
two with Jana Pam Nishi drawing first
blood in the match with a fantastic win
with black apart from that we've often
seen in the match the player playing
Black has struggled to neutralize out of
the opening now Jan hasn't lost a single
game in this match with black thing
meanwhile not just in this match with
the black pieces
thing has not yet defeated janapamnushi
in this world championship match as well
as any of the classical games that
they've played against each other
Robert is not going to have a
psychological effect on ding going into
today's game
yeah ding has not beaten young Palms who
with the black pieces I don't think he
is going to be aiming for that today if
an opportunity arises he will try to
make the most of it but you can see Jana
palmchi there same salmon colored shirt
same strong mental fortitude same
fantastic chess player as we've seen
throughout this world championship so
for ding he knows his opponent at this
point and he knows that he can't just
drum up a win out of nowhere he would
have to take some serious risk and I
just don't think ding dude needs to do
that at this late stage he still has two
white games remaining I don't think now
is the time to let things go crazy
just four games remaining two getting
our 17th Chess World Champion Fabi are
you surprised to see Yan return with a
pink shirt or not as much
well I I'm not as his stylist but if I
were I would tell him you know maybe to
try the different color you know they
say uh
variety is a spice of life so let's see
some different colors for these last few
games but I think that uh these last few
games will be very interesting as you
said Jan has never lost to ding with the
white pieces and that's very relevant
but I still think that Ding should try
to take his chances you know just
because things haven't happened in the
past doesn't mean that they can't happen
today or or potentially in the remaining
black game that they will have and I
want to push back a little bit on what
Robert said because
even though we have seen didn't create a
lot of Chances with the white pieces I
feel like it is possible he has
exhausted his repertoire of ideas with
white and that might be why we saw the
last game he he didn't he wasn't fully
perfectly prepared for this bishop C5
move that Jan came out with and I feel
like he's he's trying to you know probe
a little bit in in various directions
trying to find some sort of weaknesses
in Jan's opening repertoire but he might
have already used his main ideas in the
earlier stages in this match
[Music]
thing because even as press conference
ding actually confessed to
being out of his preparation by move
nine with that move Bishop C5 that you
mentioned by Yan we've seen ding come up
with these very combative energetic
opening surprises but then with a one
slight deviation Bayan which perhaps is
not the top move it feels as if ding
tends to go into a thing and finds
himself out of his familiar preparation
Robert has that surprised you a little
bit the fact that Ding is the one who is
playing these amazing variations and
these different openings but very
quickly is also the one who goes into a
think tank
well to push back against Fabiano's
pushback here we're good friends we can
argue sometimes I think that dink said
to himself that he was interested in
Risk minimization because of the
critical moment when he took that pawn
on D6 yesterday and traded Queens he
could have dropped his Bishop back
that's actually what Fabiano was
recommending that would have provided
him more winning chances he seemed a bit
nervous he just wanted to get down to
the end game where he couldn't possibly
lose nothing could go wrong there so I
feel to answer your question directly
Tanya has been a bit surprising but I
think that Ding diren has shown his
emotions I think that he has been quite
upfront with everybody watching that he
is nervous that things aren't going
exactly his way but he still is within
the territory where he can win this
match he's only one point behind and as
we see the players getting seated there
in the in Kazakhstan I mean dingley red
he knows what he needs to do today and
that is not loose
to push back on both of you pushing back
and say that definitely for a world
championship preparation things prepped
today has to not lack that debt he
cannot afford to burn the clock early on
Yan playing with the white pieces thing
has to be sure that he has those
critical minutes uh reaching time
control reaching move 40 it is something
that Yan can play on by not taking too
much risk perhaps in the opening stages
but making sure that he poses the big
question when the clock runs low we see
both players seated I'm expecting the
jackets to come off meticulously be
placed uh on the chairs first moves are
about to happen and of course that begs
the question to be asked one E4 by Yan
is that a mutual vote
I'm gonna go with yes I think E4 I don't
think it's time to experiment Rihanna
because
as as you guys both pointed out he's
he's in the lead and there's no reason
to take unnecessary risk uh you know
you're in the lead of course you're
playing with the white pieces and I
think Jan will still have some ambition
of course in this game but he's not
going to want to put himself in a
position where he's potentially losing
the game that would be a complete
disaster and putting not only back in
the match but arguably as a favorite
especially you know uh in the
psychological sense because winning with
the black pieces and such a crucial game
that would be so huge psychologically
and in the match score so I think E4 and
you know what I hope to see I don't know
if I expect it but I hope to see a
sicilian night Earth you actually said
that yesterday Fabi and Robert you were
quite amused with that prediction uh at
the close of the show after game 10 and
I have to ask you what are the chances
of us actually seeing a night off today
Robert
yo this is one where I trust Fabi and I
think that it would be excellent to see
a night or and I just want to say I
agree completely with what fabi's been
saying and I'm looking at this game I'm
looking at the opening stage Jan has had
adventures with the white pieces uh
let's not forget that two games ago in
game nine Jan actually had an advantage
and he was disappointed with that draw
so he is an ambitious player if the
situation occurs where he can play for
an edge he will do just that but he
wants to minimize his own risk uh the
players I mean they're seated they're
ready I think that dingley Ren he's
looking at this board intently and I
think we should all intently wait for
his first move because if it's C5 it's a
sicilian Bobby you're gonna be a proud
proud commentator and colleague of
dingley red
oh I I will be super proud but you know
I don't know what I would do if I was in
his position it's easy to say play the
Sicilian go all out you know try to take
advantage of perhaps Jan's
um uncertainty in terms of should I play
for a win should I play it solidly that
is a sort of vulnerable psychological
state where you can try to uh and here
we see the first move E4
played not a surprise but will Yan
because he's not obligated to to uh play
the
that first move he's taking it back will
he uh
will he play it or will he choose
something else I think it's just taken
back to make it himself and we see that
Ding get off get up take off the jacket
he's gonna sit right back and we're
gonna have handshakes and the start of
the game wow 184 is what we're expecting
it's gonna be a big shocker if Jana
actually decides to play something else
simply because he's been getting such
great positions out of the opening
ding's the one who's been challenged to
neutralize White's advantage and as the
match
etches towards that Finish Line it
becomes that much more difficult
psychologically the pressure increases
to get out of the opening without too
much trouble thing so far hasn't been
that successful in this one guys one E6
the French I don't believe that's going
to happen the clocks have started one E4
that call was an easy one to make with
dingler in what will he start with will
he reach out for C5 no he goes with E5
the king spawn opening Fabi you look
disappointed
a little bit okay are we going to see a
Berlin again yeah I feel like it's going
in that direction because it was a very
successful opening for ding in the last
game where he played with the black
pieces
going back to the anti-martial
he's he's hesitating here a bit but I I
think he'll probably go for the Berlin
I don't think so Fabi I think the fact
that he's thinking right now I'm I'm
gonna say it's not going to be a Berlin
and we have a move it's the Spanish
you called it it'll be probably an
anti-martial unless well ding
will dingo for an orchangelisk B5 Bishop
C5
I mean he's shown that he's surprising
him in every game he's playing a
different opening every game but he
reverts to his usual repertoire the
Marshall
Robert at this stage I would love to see
your Marshall happen do you think uh Jan
will allow that or will he go for an
anti-martial
I think he'll go for an anti-martial I
mean there's no reason why he should go
into the treacherous territory that is
the Marshal used in so many World
Championships past and I think that for
Yan he's just trying to think what does
dingley Wren want from me and there it
is he plays D3 uh we're starting with
these closed variations it's going to be
a slower build up and I think a good
choice by both of these players because
for ding he plays his normal repertoire
it works very well for him a couple days
ago from the opening stage he made that
Rook B8 a bit of a timid move but if he
doesn't show hesitation there's no
reason why he should fear the opening
stage as he's proving with the black
pieces he can do quite well
and and this was how young beatding in
the 2020 candidates
a very crucial game which was uh
instrumental you could say in Jan
winning the 2020 candidates and
qualifying for his first world
championship match in 2021. and so the
game will probably continue A3 here
is also A4 there's C3
audio A3 C3 uh was what we saw earlier
in the match
but
but A3 is is the main move and now the
question is will ding play Knight A5 C5
immediately or will he Castle Knight C3
and then likely Knight A5 I think he'll
go for the very modern approach Knight
A5 Bishop A2 C5
White's idea in these positions is to
develop the Knight to C3 and Black's
idea is usually to get that knight from
C6 to a better Square uh to open up the
path of the C Pawn to gain a bit more
space in the center
although there's
so the game in the 2020 candidates
continued Castle
I'd see three Knight A5
Bishop A2 Bishop to E6
and uh and here B4
and Bishop takes a two Rook a two
knights C6 Bishop G5
Knight to D7
or no not not Knight to D7 sorry I think
it was actually
uh
you're allowed to D7 yes because you're
allowed to forget Fabi it's okay but
apparently your memory uh kicked right
now I I saw this game recently
um when reviewing the the recent games
between or the past games between uh Jan
and and ding the past decisive games and
this was obviously a very important one
and white took on a six played 95 and
like surprisingly allowed the Knight
takes F6 this was obviously preparation
by both players but Jan came better
prepared and won a very very interesting
game
and ding is hesitating because black has
a really major Choice here does he want
a castle or Knight A5 first and the
modern approach is to is to not Castle
is to play Knight A5 immediately
and after Bishop A2 C5
actually ding played this Against Me In
2016.
uh Knight C3
Bishop to E6 and I played Knight to H4
and also some sort of modern Theory at
the time it was considered dubious for
black but these days it's considered
completely fine for black
very often black is trying to play C4 to
uh
completely shut off that Bishop 182 and
White's idea is to play Knight of five
for example if Castle here Knight to F5
I think this is like big Theory Bishop
F5 EF5 D5
otherwise white will gain the white
Square's Bishop to G5 attacking
indirectly attacking that pawn D5 and
then C4 and
some sort of uh
very unclear Theory and I don't remember
exactly the details but I think Rook to
E1 here or queen to E1 is some sort of
some sort of theory it's considered a
good line for black but it's very
confusing because tactically speaking
it's very close to being uh bad for
black for example I think this queen D1
move is is at this moment and it's also
preparing Rook to D1
as well as attacking E5 and iron A5 so
it's a very multi-purpose move
uh could we could see something like
this it's it's not out of the question
at all
but I actually suspect that Yan will
have some new idea in this line because
as we know ding is has been a lifelong
martial player so for yawn this was like
a main point of Interest before the
match so of course he he would come to
this opening armed with ideas in all
sorts of variations that's that's to be
expected we already saw he had two very
serious ideas earlier in this match
against Andy Marshall so I suspect we'll
see a third very serious idea and I just
want to continue this line one couple
more moves because if black plays H6
just to illustrate fabi's point then
Knight takes D5 is available the queen
on d8 is overloaded needed to defend the
Knight here because the queen takes
Knight Queen takes Knight in return
white steals a pawn so a very
instructive line a very deep variation
and Fabi what we're seeing on the board
right now this may be one of the
variations not that end line because
that would be a blunder but we see C5
and Knight C3 so following the path that
you just laid out for us
yeah I think Bishop E6 is the move here
and
after Bishop to E6 will he play Knight
H4 or there's some positional lines
involving Bishop to G5 but Knight H4 is
the most critical move
but yeah Jana is going for it's a
similar to approach to to when we saw
that earlier game where he played um an
early C3 instead of A3
and then he tried to chop off the Knight
on F6 and he indeed he did with the idea
of exploiting the D5 Square so it seems
like Jan just likes these positions in
principle it's actually so similar to
that game from a positional strategic
point of view uh I think black is going
to you know make some move which allows
Bishop takes F6 for example short Castle
here should be quite a normal move
and then we see the trade-off between
the bishop pair and the light Square
outpost on the D5 Square
yeah one of the big drawbacks of putting
your pawns two squares apart is a square
in between is your opponents for the
taking that's why the bishop came to G5
to take this Knight on F6 and then plop
a pony on D5 and very instructive is
that typically speaking you don't want
to take this bishop on E6 that does
double Black's pawns and for those of
you who are new to chess you've heard
that double pawns are bad because they
can't protect each other but here a Pawn
on E6 would actually cover some very
important squares let's it's not just
the D5 Square let's not forget fabi's
big idea of Knight H4 to F5 that's not
going to happen if there's a pawn
sitting on E6 not to mention there's
also an open f file for The Rook once
the king castle so just you're not
taking on E6 that's not the point of
this variation it is to put that Knight
on D5
yeah this is going to be a very
interesting strategic battle there there
are many concrete lines here
I don't think that black should try to
avoid sometimes you play Knight to D7 to
avoid the trade of Bishop for Knight to
keep that Knight which is a better
defender of the light squares obviously
than dark Square Bishop which could
never ever control those light squares
but here it looks like black heavy not
Castle probably should take the
opportunity to Castle before uh you know
before allowing the position to become
concrete
and
yeah then white will probably at some
point take on F6 I think that will
happen
I mean there's no other idea behind
Bishop G5 besides taking that and then
we have a position which is similar to I
forget which game was it um as you can
help me out here where we saw this
structure and this this uh
it's a game
I'm trying to remember now myself
because they're all they all sort of
merge together I think game five is game
five correct because
think lost a second through the third
one the fourth and lost the fifth so it
could have been game five
it sounds right where there eventually
was the open E file the Knight versus
the bishop and uh that's exactly what
we're talking about right you take this
uh 9 out of six you leave black within
questionable dark Square Bishop so I
believe it was game five of course we
can verify that pretty easily but in
that game the a file was opened up which
generally speaking I would consider to
be a bit of an advantage for white
compared to having it closed here
because I think if white ever plays A4
in this sort of position like we'll
probably play B4 at this point just
because it's such a space gain sort of
gains uh so much space on the queen side
and keeps the a file closed you know the
Knight on A5
it's actually quite a decent piece if A4
B4 happens so Knight D5 immediately we
see
we could see here a number of ideas for
black
I mean Knight C6 is the most obvious
move because you kind of avoid B4 stuff
you you get your knight back into the
center a little bit and long-term plans
like G6 to drop the bishop back to G7
where it can't be captured
and uh you know I think in that earlier
game we saw the fight between why trying
to get h4h5
and black wasn't quite in time to play
H5 himself to prevent that expansion
so G6 immediately makes a lot of sense
but Knight C6
or G6 might not have changed a whole lot
here
well you've been talking about an
expansion on the Queen's side right and
you mentioned the move Knight C6 which
kind of does fight against ideas would
be focused because it allows the a pawn
to advance after that but then this move
G6 just mixing up the move order it does
give Yan the opportunity to go
immediately with the move B4 that is
very committal the other plans in these
positions Fabi have always been to push
the C Pawn first so you go C3 and then
you try and get B4 in you just delay it
keep it a bit flexible either B4 or A4
it gives you the time to decide that are
you expecting Jan I see him he's also
thinking about this he was perhaps
expecting the night Retreat before this
Pawn Advance on the king side but of
course as always Yang plays quickly he
plays fast a non-committal move Queen D2
with a big direct threat watch out for
that Knight on A5 the queen on d8 you
pointed it out in another position
Robert it is overloaded currently
defending that Bishop on F6 defending
that Knight on A5 so Knight F6 is a big
threat looks like it's time to come back
with that Knight Knight C6 coming up
I think so and I think the point of this
move is in case black plays Bishop G7 at
some moment white may consider the move
Knight to G5
uh
I think probably Knight C6 instead of
Bishop G7 it looks a bit safer for black
but in in many variations that will that
will certainly come to mind as an option
and after Knight C6 what's his idea it
could be to play A4
because you mentioned that c3b4 idea but
with the queen on D2 I don't see that as
preparing c3b4 so watch feels like maybe
A4 is the is a plan because now with B4
is there some sort of like a
five stuff
I don't know
because Knight Texas loses a piece
knight F6 followed by Bishop takes E6
little tactic there
and
the idea of A5 from a like strategic
sense is to make the A6 Pawn a bit of a
long-term weakness
and but then there's Bishop G7 I don't
know if this makes any sense for white I
can play
like to be six here but it might be a
bit of a senseless
uh
senseless Pawn Advanced A5
yeah because the A5 Pawn might just be
captured at some point in the near
future and the bars going up and down a
little bit so it's still relative
equality but it just feels like that
pawn may not be too long for this board
in summer I was just hoping like Bishop
to C4 here would uh would maybe
encourage
like to take on C4
and basically I want to trade those
Bishops because I want to leave a pure
uh bad Bishop position right the bishop
on G7 versus alone Knight would be the
ideal goal
but uh you know one player I Look to as
uh like trying to combat this sort of
bad Bishop
narrative is is Magnus because at some
point he was playing the swashnikov
and he was playing a very specific line
against the rosalimo which is White's
main main way of combating or trying to
avoid special and he was playing very
specifically with a very bad Bishop on
G7 with pawns on C5 and E5 and then
white would play H4 H5 and he would even
play H6 and G5 so he put all his pawns
on dark squares with that Bishop on G7
and you would think what an awful piece
how could How could a strong player ever
want to go for that sort of position but
it turns out that
uh the bishop is a very good defender of
the dark squares and if the position
ever opens up the bishop starts to like
terrorize all the dark squares so it
actually discourages the opening up of
the position which means that white
doesn't have as much strategic potential
for example in this position if white
ever goes for F4 ideas the bishop
suddenly becomes very powerful so this
bishop bad though it may be kind of
discourages white from opening the
center which c3d4 with F4 and and
various other typical ideas in in
similar positions
yeah and the chat who's saying that Ding
will try to push for a win today that
would be the dream but given the math
situation and playing with black here's
a reminder of a fun fact that thing has
actually never won a game with the black
pieces against yan yan has never lost
with white against Ding and second as we
were mentioning in the open as well that
the feeling is that for today's game
it's more important for ding to hold to
keep things under control than to push
extra hard for a win with the black
pieces when you're trying to win you
need to take risks you need to create
chances for both sides the forest that
Fabio were earlier alluding to the
forest of Michael tal where you draw
your opponent in and the path to get out
is narrow enough for just one of them
and that would mean big risk at this
stage dingler and cannot afford to lose
a game I have to ask you guys we're on
move 14 right now ding is thinking
currently given the position the way
it's gone who has this opening been a
success for it
well I would say you're on the palm tree
just based on the amount of time that he
spent based on the position itself
Black's plan is not abundantly clear we
just mentioned several plans for white
C3 B4 uh kind of trying to break open
the position if black tries to keep the
bishop there then this move Knight G5 is
really annoying to deal with and I I
feel like one of the big questions and I
know the chat has been asking this is
how to unbalance the position in this
opening and we should already take stock
that black has a dark Square bishop and
white has an extra Knight so that is in
a way an unbalanced position right that
is not the same pieces for each side but
the problem is this dark Square Bishop
as Fabiano was talking at length about
it just doesn't have open terrain it may
discourage white from Pawn breaks
because if this bishop stays on the
board a typical idea like F4 is not very
appealing if the bishop gets an open
diagonal but it's just going to stare
into its own pawns whereas the knights
well they actually exert their force on
the position the net F3 is not so great
but if the bishop drops Back Then That
Knight hops forward to G5 so that does
look promising for white the D5 Square
control is great the fact that white
controls some of the pawn breaks is
really nice namely B4 and black
certainly does not want to take on B4 to
open up this Rook on A1 to a backwards
Pawn so I feel like white does have a
bit more flexibility to the position but
all that being said black is super super
solid there's no target in the position
to exploit so I think the move Knight C6
or even the move Bishop G7 allowing
Knight G5 both of them moves are options
I would prefer Knight C6 I don't want to
see my opponent's pieces hop forward so
I think bringing that piece from the rim
back towards the center would be the
good start
about is that what are the
champ follow up on the point that you
were making that perhaps if ding does
want an unbalanced approach for this
game
yes the idea of Knight C6 looks super
safe but maybe that might incline him
and push him towards in fact that Bishop
Retreat that we've been talking about
because the point of that Bishop Retreat
or what we might not like with white
after that is the move Knight to G5 but
if you just look at that position a
little closer and let's say that black
was actually to lose the light squared
Bishop on E6 doubled up those Pawns in
the center but what you get in return is
more control over that D5 Square an
openf file to me at first that looks
like exactly the kind of unbalanced
position that you want if you're in a
must-win situation so let's say you come
back with your knight to C6 right now
fall back with the Knight and if white
was to take on E6 of course this is a
decision that you can delay but to speak
structurally this is quite an imbalanced
middle game you've doubled your pawns
openf file the queen can come to E7 once
the Knight falls back the E6 Pawn is
attack you can step up with your queen
connect your Rooks Knight someday can
jump to D4 double up on the file Bobby
is this the kind of position that will
give both players chances
yeah this is a very difficult strategic
decision for for white to make because
as you pointed out uh The White Square
Bishop being off the board would be a
bad thing for black because of the
weakness of the D5 square but upon
coming to E6 gives a lot of control to
that D5 square and if white for example
draws back to Knight to E3 which sooner
or later probably white will have to not
at the moment
you know the not only five D5 is not
directly threatened but it will be soon
uh yeah this this would be better but I
can simply play you know some move like
Rook to C8 for example to defend the
Knight or King to AJ to get the king out
of the way of the diagonal uh looks
especially reasonable and okay so white
at some point plays Knight to E3 and
black defends the E6 Pawn probably with
Queen to E7 comes to mind as a very
logical way
uh and yeah the question is what what
does white achieve with this because
where are your Pawn breaks okay A4 will
probably be by B4 I don't see how that
improves a position so much for what C3
and D4 will never happen black controls
D forward literally for attackers and C3
and B4 but the question is do you
actually want to take on C5 and if not
what is the point of C3 and B4 so I
don't see why it's direct play here
which means that black who has a direct
idea to someday prepare D5 King and
shade rook d8 and maybe Queen F7 maybe
bishop page six something to prepare D5
black has the idea so
I'd prefer black I'd prefer to play with
the black pieces in this type of
position and that's why I agree with you
that maybe Knight G5 takes E6 is not a
very dangerous strategic approach so
what would I do in case someday Bishop
drops back to G7
because as we saw in the featured chat
um the question was
will we see uh unbalanced complications
and I think at the moment the position
is very unbalanced not not in terms of
complications there's no tactics at the
moment no big tactics but it is very
unbalanced in the sense that
like as a bishop pair white has light
Square control and an outpost on D5 but
black has that long-term idea of King h8
and F5 and starting play on the king
side that's a pawn break which uh black
has and white has on breaks as well but
but that one really comes to mind Knight
C6 King h8 and of course not with the
Knight on G5 but someday F5 move
could come and
you know the typical King's Indian sort
of on storm attack right we've seen this
in in the king's Indian
and he plays Bishop G7 immediately not
Knight C6
and I think that was a critical decision
right in chess we speak of these
critical moments which often in our head
is about long calculations uh tactics
that might be coming on but very often
it is these positional decisions
deciding which Bishop to give deciding
which kind of a middle game are you
really aiming for Knight to C6 would
have given up the dark Squad Bishop for
ding while the move Bishop G7 invites
Yan to grab up that Bishop on E6 and as
our chat was forecasting that would mean
an imbalanced middle game an imbalanced
approach to this game and then goes for
it Robert do you think this uh decision
by him which looks slightly slightly
well aggressive more aggressive than the
one of falling back with the Knight
using that is uh influenced by the math
situation
I think just a good move I mean the more
that we talk about the position the more
I'm thinking well maybe ding's opening
is working out for him because if Knight
G5 isn't particularly scary to meet then
we have a position where it's not just
going to be symmetrical Pawn structure
same pieces and let's just shake hands
no right now only one side has a dark
Square bishop and it is dingly Wren
whether or not that's a good piece
remains to be seen and the last thing
that Dave wants to do is ever take this
Knight on D5 and allow the bishop into
the D5 squared that would be a mistake
so after Knight G5 we keep talking about
this allowing white to take on E6 I
think that would be a beneficial
exchange for black but both sides have
some things that are going their way uh
this bishop on A2 would stare down this
diagonal at a pawn on E6 which means
that Palm would need to be defended and
where Black's continuation would come
from is honestly just as difficult to
spot as whites because if we could just
look at that line once more say Knight
G5 Knight C6 uh takes takes and as Fabi
was saying you can spend a move your
knight is not under attack because this
tactic if Bishop takes D5 would be check
and this Knight would be threatened so
C3 is a useful move and if we like King
h8 the Knight back to E3 Queen E7 this
type of position I mean what is the risk
in this position for white I'm not
really seeing any big issues so so he
did play his move and actually I wanted
to ask a question because a move
suddenly occurred to me and I know we
said it should never be played but after
Knight C6 my eye fell on this move F4
and since he played the move it might
become relevant and the point is if e
takes a four yes you opened up your
Bishop on the long diagonal but Knight
takes E6 fv6 and Knight takes F4 and
you're just losing that E6 spawn and it
doesn't the B2 Pawn is rather irrelevant
compared to that one and here it just
looks like I don't know what does black
do I mean I don't
see any good move maybe maybe it's
already bad for black in fact so after
F4 how are you continuing because if you
take on D5 Bishop D5 is super disruptive
hitting that Knight on C6 and doesn't
look very good for black either so
so F4 what is the response
and while you guys contemplate that I'm
gonna give you a fun fact in this
position I know you boys are gonna love
this one so Jan won for the move Knight
two five right according to my data base
there's only one game that I have in
front of me with the move Bishop to G7
in that position Knight C6 was played
more often and Robert if we just back
back up to that moment right before
Knight G5 happen so there's one game
that's been played in which white went
Queen to G5 and it continued with F6 and
the queen falling back to E3
I'm gonna give you three guesses who
played with white rabbit it's a good
friend of yours Mouse slip because
Knight to G5 was the correct
um a good friend of mine
[Music]
um
Bobby did you play this
was that a trick question yeah you would
remember I don't think so
it wasn't Fabi but it was Daniel
naroditsky who played this position with
the white pieces he won Queen G5 it was
in a title Tuesday against Tang Andrew
tang and the game eventually ended in
White's favor Queen Depot was Daniel's
move of choice in that Blitz game but of
course Knight G5 just feels like the
move that you've got to make here I
gotta say I'm a bit concerned by how
many games in this world championship
match are following either title Tuesday
games or Lee chess games between
Anonymous accounts
there's there's been a lot of them I
mean like yesterday was also a title
Tuesday game but Bayonne himself
especially was was quite funny but now
we're following another title Tuesday
game by Dania and or almost because Jan
did DVA with what appears to be a more
dangerous move I wonder what oh what
ding had in mind when he played Bishop
G7 because
maybe he thought Knight C6 and he and
then suddenly he sees that F4 is
quite a scary little
uh little Pawn thrust
so
on the other hand
if white can
I mean it's not a move with like a super
direct threat okay F5 is a threat but
how does black responses maybe bishop to
D7 is that
is
n't there some problem down this line
yeah but fe595 the Knight does cover
uh the F7 Pawn
is that five super strong here I guess
it's F5
yep it is F5 good good find there I mean
the problem is this pressure is just
overwhelming after fg6 there you likely
will lose material at some point down
this line and Bishop H6 I think this is
important line to show for everyone that
it looks like you're pinning this Knight
but it's not a king behind the Knight
it's not an absolute pin which means the
Knight can still move uh in many of
these lines first of all F6 might also
be unpleasant H4 is available but I'm
wondering at some point can I just take
this Pawn on F7 probably
it's so tempting I don't think it works
right here because if there was a rook
on D1 it would work beautifully but
right
but what if we just play F6 I I mean
okay I don't care about all your your
threats I don't care if I'm not mating
you immediately long term that King is
is not going to be very happy
no because you can't even go King h8
because then my idea works perfectly
it's not an absolute pin then I can
legally move you have to take because
you're in check and then I get your
Bishop over here and I'm gonna check
with you in the near future most likely
so
um this line after F4 it looks very
scary and I guess we have to do our due
diligence and try to come up with ideas
for black Bishop D7 doesn't work out
because of F5 most moves probably won't
really work out because of F5 we said
taking on F4 doesn't help because of the
Knight takes E6 line at the very least
white will win a pawn there
is there like a Nike I'm scared to make
a move like this I was thinking about
that but then I yeah Knight t7
definitely because it stops at five
and Knight takes E6 fe6 97 Queen E7
and now F5 is very critical
but black certainly can play gf5 EF5
and
is D5 safe fe6 Queen E6 it doesn't seem
to be a problem because you can't attack
D5 very clearly and I'll play C4 next
and you know
we saw this idea in some similar lines
some other lines from this variation
where the bishop gets locked out of the
game if the bishop was on for example F3
I think this position would be pretty
dubious for black but official 1a2 could
get really uh restricted very quickly
so maybe I was also thinking after 95
maybe bishop to H6 uh sorry after uh
f906 F4 baby Bishop to H6 is
is a possible move
because you can't move your f-pawn
anymore
right but H4 Maybe
just throw your pawns for this it looks
ridiculous right white is just throwing
all the kingside Pawns of the board the
side that he's castled on and yet it's
working out because white is the one who
is launching the attack first I mean
this bishop on A2 it's just waiting in
the wings the opening of the f-file
could be very dangerous for this black
king and Knight takes E6 at some point
will be in the question not to mention
this F5 Pawn thrust it looks really
dangerous for black
yeah H4 would be an idea that's
definitely in the air in many such
positions to try to advance the F Pawn
and Knight G5 it the fact that Bing
played Bishop G7 and then goes into
another long think after Knight G5 a
seven minute thing a it's a bit
concerning he's got enough time and he
should be taking a lot of time in this
position but Knight G5 is of course the
first response that you look at after
you make the move Bishop to G7 the
retreating move is ding uncomfortable
Robert you mentioned that Yan's the one
who can feel slightly uh slightly
a small victory there out of the opening
this feeling that well it's been more
successful for white than for black
because of the time management and I
think it's safe to say that Ding is
feeling the heat after this Knight G5 F4
idea that you've been discussing
yeah fobby's F4 idea we it's funny
because he led me to believe it wasn't
possible because it opens up this bishop
and then as soon as I stopped thinking
about it he's like oh what about F4 that
looks like a good try it does look quite
dangerous for black uh because white is
the one throwing pawns forward uh that
being said we see the eval bar off to
the side so we know that Ding probably
knows that as well this is really just
out of the opening stage uh he is
spending time I think quite wisely
because black has several good looking
options Knight to C6 as we've been
talking about uh it looks like the main
move uh they're moving Bishop back to D7
that doesn't really feel right at first
glance to me because you are allowing
this bishop on A2 to shine but maybe
then black will kick the night out from
G5 try to play King h8 and F5 play this
in the king's Indian style that's not
completely out of the question so if
ding is thinking about this from a match
perspective I want to win the game then
Bishop D7 trying to get H6 in becomes
more appealing I'm just really scared
I'm being honest with everybody I'm
scared of this bishop on A2 on an open
diagonal
everything said you were mentioned
everything that you're mentioning I'm
also slightly surprised simply with
ding's time management here because this
is in fact a position that he has had
himself not even a year ago it was in
the speed Chess Championship with the
black pieces ding had this position
playing against nehal Serene but it was
the move Queen D2 that was the new move
by Yan
and despite that Ding has to be familiar
with these setups he knows the dangers
that are there this is a world
championship level prep that we're
talking about so us feeling that Ding is
feeling the heat right now and the fact
that he's gone into this Think Tank
having played this position with the
black up till the point that Gan
deviated with the move Queen D2 it's
definitely concerning for uh for ding
fans especially when you're faced with
this problem that white is actually
going to just spawn storm down on the
King fire and create and develop this
attack probably how worried would you be
with black hair
I would be rather concerned and I think
there is a reason why although he had
his position
that he might not you know be super
super well uh
familiar with with all the subtleties
here which is that it's not a very
concrete position so you can easily get
confused with all the move orders do I
play 96 first do I play Bishop G7 first
uh instead of Queen D2 white hat for
sure like several options so a lot of
that can can lead you to not remember
every single detail of of every possible
move that white has so I'm not surprised
that he's um he's thinking because as we
saw also in this match he's played like
you know five different openings against
E4 so uh being able to play so many
openings it naturally means that you
might you know because you have to
remember so much in so many openings
that you might be less familiar with
with all the subtleties in a certain
sideline but I actually had a question
for you guys uh
do you do you feel comfortable when
you're being attacked like this when
your opponents being aggressive are you
more like I'm happy to defend and then
counter attack or are you I I want to
attack and I want to be aggressive and I
don't want to be on the back foot in the
game
Robert do you want to go first or should
I I was letting you go first I was
curious what you had to say
yeah no definitely I would want to be
the one who's on the attacking side the
one who's exerting pressure and I think
that would be uh the scenario for most
of us it's never it's never Pleasant you
have to deal with these decisions out of
the opening especially out of the
opening I think once it happens when
you're way into the middle game things
change tactics of all strategy changes
it's still fine to be on defense from
time to time but coming out going into
move 15 and feeling that your opponent
is building this uh this attack on the
king side of opening up the f file F4
coming in I would at this moment
definitely start feeling the nerves and
feeling uncomfortable uh and yeah I
don't know about you Robert but I would
not want to be black right now
yeah I think to answer your question
Fabi I'm not home off like what do you
want from me I'm not this and crazy
resourceful Defender who doesn't mind my
king being blasted open just because I
can prove every single time that I could
calculate one step further I typically
don't really mind that much about my
king being attacked uh but I would
definitely favor the side for example if
the bishop dropped back I would love
this bishop money too I think just the
peace placement is also glorious for
white at this stage so it's not like
you're all in on this attack and then
you've completely compromised your
structure that's why I feel like in this
particular position uh White is doing
quite nicely and I did want to show one
quick variation because I think some
people will be tempted to pin this
Knight on G5 and it's something I was
mentioning before just because there is
a more valuable piece behind this Knight
doesn't mean that the Knight can't move
so just to quickly show a line here is
that if Bishop H6 were to be played
white doesn't just have to defend the
knight in fact white will take the
bishop because if you take back I get
your Bishop thank you very much so
you're gonna take my queen oh that's a
good Queen but so is yours thank you and
after Rook takes here we have a position
with Bishops of opposite color but this
isn't just some equal end game that's
not what we're seeing at this point I
think white strikes first with F4 you
could also throw in Rook D1 first maybe
that's even better but my major point
was after Pawn takes a knight takes F4
here if we get a position where you have
to do this I'm wondering if the pressure
down an F7 that Bishop sitting on A2 uh
it's maybe promising for white I'm not
positive about all this clearly the evil
bar doesn't fully agree but Fabi I was
just wondering what would happen if this
kind of transition occurred yeah this
could be promising for what although
King G7 followed by F6 does defend
against the immediate threats but
certainly black would not want to allow
that position with the Knight on D5 with
obvious color Bishops outposted there
even if white doesn't do anything
special even white plays C3 here uh
followed by you know maybe a four B4 uh
looks like a pretty lousy end game and
you might draw this but you're not
having any fun doing so but ding played
a different move and it's not one we
consider it's a very exciting one C4
we did mention this idea you uh cut off
the bishop on A2 as as you said very
strong piece so
definitely good to get it uh to get it
out of the game a little bit on the
other hand that C4 Pawn it's you know
it's a bit of a tender spot as well if
that if that pawn Falls then everything
falls for black so this is very concrete
all of a sudden
and I'm thinking white should take on E6
at this point because well you kind of
want to deal with the bishop takes D5
threat which is now a threat why would
not want to capture with the pawn and
double the pawns and spoil the structure
somewhat so
but then after fe6 do you play an ite3
certainly comes to mind but then
what uh what happens next Bishop to H6
Maybe
okay I feel 96 fe6 93 is this is a
critical line like that's the first
thing you calculate
D5 just loses a pawn because ed5 ed5 95
it's exactly like that line you
mentioned before pretty much to a t the
same tactic although in a very different
position
and queen D5 Queen A5 white is probably
just completely at least up a pawn and
it looks like a pretty important Pawn to
me so
after 93 Watts move Works C8 is coming
to mind for sure
why not Bishop 86 after 93 the ideas
that we've been looking at yeah I
thought Bishop H6 is a really natural
move as well but I was worried maybe
that white will play Rook 8 D1 and
Target that d-pawn
but who knows this is
some sort of mass for sure
you should buy ding very committal and
look at Jan he's got that pose that we
saw from him back in game nine where he
feels that perhaps he's he's got some
opportunity here he's got he's got a bit
of a chance here to try to create
something C4 a big move but a very
committal one and uh Jan there takes a
sip and decides to go into a thing
because that's what he needs to do at
this point to see how he can make the
most of this Pawn structure that we've
been looking at and while Yan does that
and comes to a decision we will go into
a shot break the game is heating up
don't go anywhere we'll be right back
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
T is an official partner of the chesscom
broadcast of the fide World Championship
they are a global firm that builds
complex mathematical models to identify
market inefficiencies now worldcon brain
is bringing together its International
Quan championship and the chess
Community to hunt down the next
generation of Quant Finance Specialists
because nobody knows how to analyze a
position better than a chess player
right if you think you have what it
takes register now for the international
Quan Championship had to go.chess.com
iqc or use command iqc in chat for more
details and we are in a critical moment
of a game 11. as we see a big move has
been made by dangleren it is playing
with fire Fabi as you were mentioning
when we went into break that's C4 just
explodes open the position you are
committing to pawn weaknesses on the
queen side what does ding have in mind
what does he get in return he shuts down
that Bishop on A2 but this is a move
that if you don't do something
immediately to neutralize the pressure
on the Pawns in a couple of moves they
could end up being down upon in this
game
yeah this is certainly very double-edged
and I'm surprised by the speed at which
he played it
we were looking at Knight C6 that was
the first move which came to mind uh to
us but I I think that thing was afraid
of f4
and this one yeah I think that Jan will
take on E6 and play 93 nothing else
comes immediately to mind as a very
obvious continuation and then black has
I think a variety of ways of defending
the C Pawn of course you don't want to
take on D3 because of the intermediate
Bishop takes E6 check
you might not even want to take on E3 in
general sense but especially now because
Bishop B6 simply wins upon
and so then you have a choice of we
already saw why D5 is a bad move so you
have to defend C4 you have either Queen
C7 Rook C8 or Bishop H6 the movie you
mentioned Tanya not defending C4
directly but defending it indirectly by
pinning the Knight on E3
and in all cases I think no matter which
move black plays white can develop the
A1 Rook to D1 because
the D6 Pawn is also a potential weakness
so black has to deal with multiple
weaknesses in the position
I think uh it's it's an opening success
for yawn it's not necessarily a much
better position but certainly he has
pressure and also safety white has less
weaknesses in Black even if things go
slightly wrong and black can
consolidates fully it's only
consolidation that's enough for equality
not for an advantage so uh yeah
excellent situation Brian especially
given the match situation you know safe
way to play for an advantage uh sign me
up I'm sure that Jan is very happy
must be at this point I mean how could
he the lines that you're showing Fabi uh
the fact that there's this D6 backwards
Pawn Rook comes to D1 it's a very
natural moves uh from White's
perspective but I've played Devil's
Advocate a little bit because if black
is able to defend both of those pawns
the bishop is shut out of play I feel
like at least you don't have a
symmetrical structure there are some
opportunities for black to push forward
especially in the event of his trade on
E6 If eventually well I can get this pod
4 to D5 those pawns start rolling I mean
ultimately I agree with you how could I
not white does have a better position
there but I'm thinking long term if Jan
doesn't keep everything under control I
could see a future where black suddenly
has some chance of his own
no that not Yan goes for the line that
you were mentioning trades off the
bishop first expecting him to also treat
the pawn on C4 I think just talking
about things thought process of putting
that move C4 on the board it's pretty
clear that he really did not want Yan to
get a free hand on the king side with
the F Pawn Advance with F4 he really
needed that Bishop on A2 to shut down so
he did take this big bit committal
decision which of course now he has to
handle the consequences of picks up the
Knight on E6 and expecting the Knight to
fall back on E3 start putting pressure
in C4 Bishop 86 was an idea that we were
looking at but Fabi the other move of
just bringing the Rook to defend that C4
Pawn one has to remember that it's not
just the C4 Pawn that's tender but also
the D6 pawn and for Yan it's just simple
moves bring that Rook the a rook to the
D file start targeting the D6 pawn and
they will have to take care of not just
one but two weaknesses in this position
is this already uh the kind of uh middle
game where Yan perhaps feels that now
he's playing for two results
I think he certainly realizes his
position is safe and also
playing for an objective Advantage
potentially so yeah in that sense
definitely two results but as Robert
pointed as well there is some long-term
potential for black if white just you
know waits around let's say Knight to E3
Queen to C7 and white starts making
silly moves that will never happen like
King to H1
Rook a to d8 and uh I don't know Rook a
to C1 obviously
something like that will never happen
then black will get the D5 push
uh yeah some completely meaningless
moves like or maybe Rook a to d8
especially
yeah and then if black gets D5 in the in
the position then uh
yeah black should be doing fine at the
very least so he does play Knight to E3
I think the most natural move here is
Queen C7 and the reason why is because
other moves allow that Rook D1 and then
it's difficult to defend D6 but here if
Rook D1 Rook 88 is at least a very
natural way of Defending that
is there a problem on C4 like there's
some variations you won't be able to
bring another Defender so for example if
I take I play Queen B4 maybe is that
an option we need two queen C3 there's a
lot of ways of doing it you know I'm
just keeping in contact with D6 so your
your d8 Rook can't go to C8 you'll lose
D6 and now I feel like you're
overwhelmed on D6 and C4
this looks pretty lousy for black indeed
maybe maybe you still have Rook to B8
and try to in the complications uh get
to some end game which is bad but not
lost uh all the Rook B2 Bishop C4 Knight
C4 Knights Rook A6 Rook A6 also
can't be too bad right
definitely can can be bad but let's why
is the engine not liking this Rook a 2
Rook A5 and C3 is that kind of like the
C Pawn remains rather powerful maybe
because Rook C5 Rook takes A3
and if I get Bishop H6 in I can fight
for that past C Pawn but
hard to say you know it looks ugly
especially especially actually Rook C5
or K3 Knight D1 just picks up that c
Pawn maybe is completely
uh completely terrible for black so
you're gonna like this is it Bishop H6
Knight C4 Rook C2 Knight takes E5 takes
F2 oh yeah that's the reason nice yeah
and it might actually is it a drone with
Rook A8 Rook A7 is that what because
Rook takes up two is just Checkmate yep
it's Rook C1 and yeah
yeah two checks on the Checkmate so
maybe white has to bail out already with
Rook A7
of Rook 8 King G7 Rook a seven and
and make a draw that way very nice spot
there yeah this is a draw
so instead
he did Play Bishop to H6
mm-hmm
ac1 we
instantly we we well he was calculating
this when he took 26 certainly so
this is exactly what we kind of
instantly felt was a natural Direction
when he played C4
why does threatening DC4 D the D6 Pawn
is a weakness
and ding is in thought so this is now
it's just a calculation position
uh for example do you have a move like
Queen to B6 I think you don't because
when Knight takes C4 so these kinds of
or it's not so so simple in fact I'm
showing that though Knight takes C4 out
of nowhere Fabi it's saying I I kept
saying earlier right just because
there's a more valuable piece behind the
night does not mean it can't move you
take my queen I take your queen I win at
least upon probably more than that and
so how does black even respond here it's
still B takes C4 Queen H6 Queen B2 is uh
the variations continuing Bishop takes
C4 is probably the best move take on C4
is absolutely forced Pawn takes and
white black has Queen takes A3 but then
Rook to D3 and Rook to H I don't know
what this is but Queen A3 I think black
is not
maybe in such a bad bad shape because
obviously there's a lot of Trumps in
Black's position as well I mean the past
day pawn
are also
Rook H3 is is met by for example Rook to
A7 so it's it's not a it's not a very
devastating attack
why does some kind of H4 ideas instead
of Rook H3 to you know just like go all
in just bust it all open uh and
who knows but I think that objectively
black is probably holding on in these
positions
so will we see Queen B6
it's it's one of the directions thing
we'll calculate undoubtedly
Queen B6 you're pointing out and I want
to ask because very often when we're
faced with this problem of so much
pressure the move that comes to mind is
to try to ease it out with trades
and what if ding decides to actually
immediately not go for these
complications to try to keep things a
little peaceful and picks up the night
on E3
should Yan consider taking it with the
F1 or would you pick it up with the
queen
uh I would consider both my instinctive
reactions of course take with the queen
keep the structure intact but would
certainly consider fe3 not so much
because of the file but more because I
want to keep an eye on the Knight on A5
and also there's another reason so let's
say black plays some move like
I mean to B6
I'm thinking an idea is to play B4
take take
with the pawn and now if Knight C6 y
plays b4n and the D4 squares covered so
that e plot actually is a very useful
Defender because if the Palms are not
two Knight D4 I think black is doing
beautifully here because the Knight
defense E6 and is an outpost but here
black
uh is left with the Knight like where's
the Knight go it's actually a bad piece
in this position and E6 is a weakness so
yeah F takes E3 definitely consideration
but taking on E3 I can't imagine this
movie being played it looks so so
ugly and like such a concession a
positional concession for black
yeah unless absolutely forced you never
want to give up that Bishop so easily
and voluntarily because white still
maintains all the trumps puts the
pressure and you're left with this
Knight on A5 the bishop on A6 is an
active piece so while it might look like
you're easing the pressure with trades
it's not one that you want and very
often one of the things that was taught
to me when I started playing chess that
when you're looking at trades and trying
to decide whether to go for them or not
is to look at what pieces you're
actually left with on the board and to
try to compare that and we can see that
if the bishop and the Knight on E3 are
in fact taken off that Knight on A5 it
does look it is on the edge of the board
it doesn't look like one that has a very
bright future meanwhile the bishop on A2
with clear Targets on the long diagonal
and so Bishop E3 is not going to be an
option big question to ding how he's
fighting towards defending that D6 Pawn
we were looking at lines that perhaps
could lead to opening up of files for
the Rooks is that an idea that actually
didn't can use to counter attack white
spawns just preempting this trade on C4
before the D6 Pawn is hit and I'm
looking at a move that we were we were
thinking about in a different variation
but let's say sliding up with that ah
Rook you either see it but I like to
move Rook B8 more I'm x-raying down the
B file and my idea is that if you go for
the D6 Pawn I will hit the soft spot on
B2 is there a way that Ding can also
look for counter player on these open
files and just play a little
prophylactic at this moment I think
that's the the trends poser for the very
least the exact line we were talking
about because if we're up to B8 uh then
here if you take on C4 and you take back
and queen take D6 and we get to this
position already there it looked like
there are some issues for white to solve
first of all black can just take on E3
trait some pieces uh take on B2 at the
end there's no way black is worse at the
end of this line because this bishop is
terrible and even if you get the Knight
on A5 I can take you can take I can take
and black is not losing this end game
with some of the worst pawns you've ever
seen I mean double isolated pawns all in
a row that's not a Connect Four where
you win the game so I think that uh this
kind of line with Rook B8 is definitely
a good option a viable option to go
after B2 and because of how forcing
these continuations are in for example
the line I just put on the board that I
think that white would be best just a
side step get out of the pin go Queen E2
put more pressure on the C4 Pawn now the
Knight can move maybe at some point
Knight G4 just to kick the bishop back
will be valuable but with the pressure
against these pawns I feel like it's
smart for Yan to keep the position close
and not allow dink just calculate his
way out
yeah I like Rook to B8
um I it didn't come to mind immediately
as a move I was considering but
now that I've seen it it looks very very
interesting
and it stops the idea of D takes C4 or
at least maybe not stops but repairs
against it for sure
so it's a very logical move from that
sounds because without that idea
yeah I can play Queen to E2 perhaps but
um
but yeah it would make sense I was
actually thinking Queen to C7 is also a
very logical move
and there was an idea behind us which
was a d takes C4 I like now I like uh
the ideas to take on E3 as you mentioned
Tanya now it's a better version I think
because ftc3 is definitely uh
concessions of Queen takes E3 looks like
the most dangerous move and now I take
on C4 with the Knight
and if Bishop takes then Pawn takes I
think black is close to equality engine
not agreeing with me as is usually the
case
but it certainly looks like a playable
position for black to the naked eye
because black will play Rook to B8 and
get some counter clay against B2 so we
see a lot of the same themes arising uh
Rook B8 Queen C7 Bishop B3 just in
different positions and different move
orders
yeah I'm totally baffled by this engine
evaluation that we're seeing in this
current position because it does look
like black would have solved all
problems with these trades right now
Fabi but it shows that white can still
put pressure and I think it comes down
to these weak pawns and white just
targeting them immediately with doubling
up on the D file but it does look like
to the naked eye that black should be
indeed fine here so ding navigating all
these possibilities once again taking
his time during the opening phase just
out of his his very familiar martial
setups and the one thing that I was
thinking about has been what we've been
witnessing during the press conferences
ding has been so candid about the
openings how he's felt out of
preparation at times especially about
game 10 when you mentioned that Bishop
C5 and it wasn't something that he had
looked at the team had looked at which
to me felt like a very big admission in
a world championship match you're kind
of giving away how much you're looking
at what's you're taking it though it's
been very candid from Ding and it's been
amazing as a fan to see those thoughts
within a world championship match is it
better to give away less
well it's usually players do tend to uh
keep it pretty close to the chest
and they they might make a lot of jokes
they might like we see Yan uh is is
often making some jokes in the press
conferences and I think Magnus was also
um sometimes like using humor to try to
evade very direct questions about
preparation or about uh let's say your
strategy for the match
and while dink has just been straight up
very honest uh
and straightforward not I mean I think
players are generally pretty honest but
they they might try to like hide things
a bit so ding ding has been like very
straightforward with what he's saying
and yeah it's hard to say I mean I don't
think it's necessarily bad because
it's more about your inner psychology
it's not so much about what you're like
showing to the outside world so
you know if you're showing vulnerability
to the outside world it's not going to
make your opponent stronger I don't
think it's only a question of uh how how
are you feeling inwardly and if it works
for ding if it doesn't affect him
negatively then I don't see a big issue
with it
some people might point to it as uh you
know some sort of like they're making
some psychological analysis that it it
shows uh weakness or something like that
but
um I don't like necessarily buy into
the accuracy of people's psychological
analysis I think you know it's it's
not like
um let's say
some professionals are necessarily
talking about this it's it's very often
the random uh talking of of Twitter and
so on so it's I don't think that we
should read too much into
um
into yeah what thing is
is saying I think it's just honesty it's
straightforwardness it's there's nothing
nothing necessarily bad or weak about it
and okay it looks like he's getting
ready to make a move I see like his body
posture his his hand is sort of ready to
go forwards uh
again body language is not something I
think I'm qualified to speak on but it
really feels like he was ready to make a
move there
yeah it does feel like a movie is about
to come well it is they need to be
careful right now he has a big decision
to make at this moment does he snap up
that night on E3 or keep thing keep
things defended by being bringing his
Queen to B6 eyeing that B2 Pawn or
perhaps a rook trade and Wilding has a
thing and we wait for him to make a move
let's take a look back this is actually
the fourth game that Ding has faced in
the Royal Lopez with the black pieces
starting from game one where Jan made
that interesting decision of taking on
C6 the Knight it ended in a draw but Jan
was the one who was pressing that game
five saw in fact a win for Yan in the
Royal Lopez and then game nine was a
draw where we saw the Berlin the
anti-belen idea of Bishop C5 and now in
game 11 ding returns with an attempt at
the Marshall countered by the
anti-martial by Ayanna Pam Nishi and
currently the move that we have on the
board is in fact one that we weren't
looking at so ding does go for the idea
of creating his own counter play in case
of trades in the center in case the pawn
is snapped up and this is just a way of
getting ready for the future by black
what you want to do is that you're
saying yes I know what you want I'm
gonna place my pieces in an optimal
point for when you go for your plan is
what he's saying to White hair if white
snaps up on C4 after taking with the
Knight the trades on C4
perhaps you start with the pawn trade on
C4 you open up the B line and snap up
the pawn and B2 Bobby you said The more
you look at this move the more sense it
makes you approve of this one
yeah I think uh you called it and then
we saw it right after and
uh it's a logical move when you consider
it you know ding saw D takes C4 is a
threat so I'm preparing against that
thread it takes a lot of this thing out
of detect C4 and maybe we'll see
Robert's move Queen to E2 here I think
it's super logical it's not the only
move I mean it there's there's
definitely a wide choice for y'all to
consider here but we also do usually see
that when given a wide Choice yawn takes
intuitive practical approach
so Queen to E2 is definitely coming to
mind as as the kind of intuitive move
right but he will
sit on that comfy chair and consider
things from the rest area for a little
bit
yeah he has the comfort of his lovely
rest area he just takes a drink of water
he's sitting on the chairs there uh ding
Loren also in his rest area uh but I
don't think that this position is one
where ding can't take too much rest
because uh this bishop that is pinning
the Knight will have to take the Knight
is a big question and that doesn't solve
all of Black's problems it does relieve
some of the tension this Pawn C4 will be
guarded more with that Knight on E3 one
of the attackers is off the board but
that's an important Bishop protecting
the king with a queen landing on E3
eventually there could be some other
problems for black to solve and let's
not forget that this Pawn on C4 it's not
going anywhere anytime soon it may be
defended but you can't really afford to
ever take on D3 because E6 will be weak
behind it so I just feel like black can
be a bit stuck and at some point white
could even throw this Pawn forward to D4
to go after this Pawn on D6 or try to
open up the D file white is better
situated along that line I really am
preferring position here I don't really
see the active counter play that would
be required for me to believe in Black's
chances here feels like a pretty
one-sided affair
hmm
yeah and we Robert this moment for Yan
why he needs to decide whether he
sidesteps with the queen or goes for the
idea that you've been uh talking about
we see that Yan is still not at his
chair we got empty chairs in front of us
the players are in the rest area
he currently looks like he's got no
intentions of actually stepping back
he's looking at the position from the
Comforts of his room so we have to ask
you at this moment that
if there is such a scenario where you've
got these live boards in front of you
and there is this position out of the
opening out of the opening well nothing
direct is happening you as a player
would you prefer to be seated in front
of the board or take a look at it from
the Comforts of the rest area just away
from the eyes of well the spectators in
the world
yeah I personally I would probably
prefer to be at the board that's just
how I concentrate best but I think it's
different for everyone and I think if I
were to make any sort of you know
analysis of this I would be taking
armchair psychologist to a whole new
level
so yeah I would probably be be at the
board firstly but for sure he could be
thinking in the rest area and still
concentrating on on the position
and the thing which worries me a little
bit about Black's position is I just so
we've been looking at like concrete ways
in which black gets in trouble
and probably black is avoiding that
uh so he's not like going to lose
material on the spot or anything
but I just realized let's say queen E2
here and queen to C7 it looks like very
logical move to me
with idea D type C4 Bishop takes E3 will
will not drop a pawn for black
okay Queen two queen C7 yep
and then I I was starting to think what
if white just plays a move like H4
uh similar to what we saw in the other
game like I I don't I don't need any
sort of concrete winning upon because I
have the idea of
uh your king side has been loosened
because the pawn from F7 went to E6 that
means that G6 is a bit more tender than
usual so if white gets ideas like H5 or
even G3 King G2 or just like slow and
then Knight G4 and Rook H1 and H5 things
like that I'm also worried long term not
just in terms of the short term uh you
know am I dropping the C4 or the D6 Pawn
but also the long term what's Black's
counter play as you said not really
clear and the Knight on A5 just can't
get back into the game because it's tied
to defensive C4 the C4 Pawn can't trade
on D3 because it needs to cover the
bishop takes E6 thread and Bishop I
don't think solves Black's problems
because the queen takes E3 or even fe3
we we mentioned that as an option and
the the same positional question remains
what's your next move and unless you're
getting D5 and which seems really
difficult for black because it just
opens up the position and creates all
these weaknesses uh I'm not seeing
blacks
like very immediate plan which means
that White's idea slow though it may be
can be dangerous H4 H5 or even G3 King
G2 and just a slow King side aggression
yeah Fabio I was thinking about a line
earlier that let's say after Queen E2
black decided to take this Knight and
play Queen B6 if you trade Queens I just
want to show what that looks like you'll
see the evaluation bar I think go at
least towards level black may even be
slightly preferred in some of these
positions because you've solved pretty
much all your problems uh this King will
happily go to F7 and the E7 your king
can walk towards the center of the board
without Queens on that King will be safe
there and protect the weaknesses in
Black's Camp which will open up many
more possibilities so instead of trading
Queens I was thinking the White Queen
slides to H3 now there's pressure on
this Pawn how do you even defend this
Pawn you play Rook to E8 I was actually
thinking about variations where white
plays this B4 push I don't think I can
get away with it right now but what if I
take and play B4 you brought this idea
to my attention earlier Bobby and the
engine approves of it that if you take I
can take back and I'm going to play B4
and I'm going to go after this pawn and
you can't even play Knight C6 because D6
is weak so all of your pawns are hanging
and you can't even take this one because
Rook B1 pins and wins this night as the
queen is behind it so I just feel like
Black's position could fall apart at any
moment if you're not super careful
yeah I think B4 is always an idea to
watch out for and especially here like
if black snack could get to D4 uh you
know as you mentioned ic6 with ID and
id4 then it would be all okay for black
item D4 covers everything beautifully
but Knight C6 allows Rook takes D6 the
Knight is simply not in time and we have
to recognize that this Knight although
it does perform useful useful function
on A5 in terms of Defending C4 it is
you know ultimately a bad piece and it
struggles to get into the game it's at
the moment just a defensive piece and
when the position opens up it will need
to get into the game but the question
then will be can it do so and in the
line you mentioned it it just doesn't
manage I think that's why probably after
DC4 Knight takes C4 would be a necessary
move in that line that we just saw
and maybe Knight 64 is holding it all
together quite decently
but of course in every all these
variations white is the one with the
with the initiative with the pressure so
pretty
pretty comfortable situation for white
on the other hand you know
we don't see the eval being tremendous
so ding is not yet in trouble but
he's under pressure and unfortunately
for him in the match situation
uh you know a position where you're
playing Just
trying to get a draw without any real
prospects of winning is not really
what he wanted to be on the menu today
because right now
that at this moment for dingler and if
he was to lose a game that would be
essentially World Championship over Jan
would be two points ahead an impossible
deficit to cover with just such few
games remaining so it's very important
for ding more important than creating
chances is to make sure that he's able
to keep things under control and make
sure that he has enough resources even
if it means defending a bad position
defending a passive position that he has
enough resources to make that happen and
he's made the move Rook to be it and we
see Yan returning to his channel while
Yan will have a think on how to counter
and go about these ideas that Robert and
Fabi have been looking at will we see a
queen move will we see a trade on C4
well we will be back after this short
break as napomnishi just goes into a
think
introducing World quad the partner of
the Champions chess tour and chess.com
[Music]
World Quant is a global firm in the
field of quantitative Asset Management
if you don't know what that is it's the
job of building complex mathematical
models that seek to identify Market
inefficiency
for 2023 World Quant brain is bringing
together its International Quant
championship and the award-winning
Champions chess tour to hunt down the
next generation of Quant Finance
Specialists that sounds very exciting
you put your skills in practice in a
case competition where you get a real
Challenge and I signed up
worldquant is seeking new talent and new
energy and it's looking at the world of
Chess to help because nobody knows how
to analyze a position better than a
chess player right no Quant experience
no problem
so
do you think you have what it takes to
compete in the international Quant
championship
sign up and be the next Quant champion
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
we see there has made a move he decides
to recapture that contemplating about
this decision it is a move 19 and we see
that he is behind on the clock but the
position does seem to be simplifying
yeah took the decision to trade that
pawn on C4 immediately a little bit of a
surprise simply because he did have the
option to delay that decision a little
bit to do to take that pawn at a more
critical moment when perhaps his Queen
on D2 was not pinned and ding
immediately comes back and responds in a
couple of minutes by recapturing with
the Knight taking advantage of the pin
along the 86 E1 diagonal
Nepal we've got a few moves coming up
nepot takes on C4 well it was the only
way to go forward and we see Bobby
Robert B line has opened up it just
looks to my eye that these trades
definitely favor Ding and whatever
chances that we were talking about the
dangers in the position with the pawn
structure with this activity along the B
line with that really nice Bishop placed
on H6 always ready to trade the E3
Knight it looks like ding will not have
too much trouble anymore things are
definitely in control for black hair
would you agree
yeah I think Robert you you called it
right before the game started it's it
this is the d word we're heading for a
draw you know I there's there's no
reason to look he's trading everything
off he had a slightly better position he
could have played on but what he is
doing is he's simplifying the Queens are
about to come off the bishop is gonna
take the Knight The Rook is gonna take
the rook and then at the end of the day
white is just gonna take a bunch of
Pawns black is also going to take a
bunch of Pawns and this is completely
balanced in the end game
yeah we're heading most likely I would
say like
98 draw uh what will happen is Queen D6
Rook D6 and Bishop E3 fp3 there's a lot
of pieces on the board but they're going
to be traded off one by one
Rook F1 King F1 will happen Rook takes
B2 will happen white will capture
I don't know maybe let's say A6 first
Rook C2 and then Rook E6
and black can play Rook to A2 Maybe
and rookie five Rook A3
uh
maybe even C3 was playable but I was
gonna say can you start getting tricky
with pushing the c3c pawn Robert before
capturing on A3
you gotta watch out because if you go
Rook C5 and I think C2 wins for black
king E1 still holds it together oh King
he won yes yes but we still see a draw
here and and like everything is going to
get blitzed out at this moment this is
pretty pretty
yeah we're seeing this all happen on the
board
yeah the thing that moves are lots of
Trades to me it looks like that capture
on C4 was essentially a draw offer by
he's saying I'm happy do not push too
much in the game simply because I'm up a
point in this match we got closer to the
finish line and the ball is in dings
Court to try to create his chances for a
win it's not gonna happen in this game
as we can see all the trades the
position that you were calling at is on
the board Rook P2 and we don't we don't
feel that either of the sides is going
to push this ending too much it's hard
to see chances anywhere here no I mean
there's just nothing available for black
to be sure and for white I think the
best that you could hope for is a pawn
up end game but with the pawns on the
same side of the board that should be
still well within the realm of a draw
and so for dingley Ren you take all the
small victories you can get it may not
be a win to level up the match but a
draw with the black pieces without
sweating too much right before the rest
day I feel like that's not the worst
thing in the world but the key thing I
just said there is rest day I think for
Jana palmchi he is going to use that
rest day well his team is going to be
looking through all the openings if well
we saw a day ago happens after the rest
day great preparation from Team
napomishi he really didn't find himself
in any difficulties because he knew the
line so much better so I think that Jan
is conserving energy he's conserving his
lead on the scoreboard and he does not
mind a draw that's about to ensue
pieces from the white pieces we've seen
intense struggles we've seen long
Marathon games and Fabi do you think
that's also playing out a little bit
that the players are perhaps running out
of steam here
I think certainly and and that's not
something they can be blamed for because
yeah this is a very long very tough
match with more decisive games at the
starter in the middle of it than we've
seen in a long long time in a world
championship match maybe going back to
like 2006 uh or 2008 you know cram next
apollov or or kremnik Anand uh these
matches which had a lot of decided games
too but at some point especially 14 game
match You're Expecting players to get a
bit fatigued and I think this decision
that Yan made to play D takes E4 instead
of Queen E2
you know we we can of course say queen
E2 it's not like it necessarily leads to
something huge for white but it's a way
to keep pressure on the position and
early on the match young plays Queen E2
I'm I'm pretty certain that he would not
immediately trade off all the pieces
basically sacrifice his white game uh
it's because he's he's probably a bit
tired he's preserving energy and also
because he has a lead in the match I
think if the score was reversed thing is
up a game there is not a single you know
uh World in which Jan would ever take on
us before down in the match he would
play Queen E2 he would press this
position until there's absolutely
nothing left not even a single chance
remaining to win the game instead he
just goes for a drawn position I think
this is uh indicative of the match score
and the match situation in terms of both
players being well especially
um in this case Jan is the only one who
really had a chance to deviate uh the
players being a little bit fatigued and
Beyond probably being perfectly happy to
take that rest day go into the three
remaining games up a point two blacks so
of course it's not uh like
you know thing won't have his fair share
of chances certainly he will remaining
three games but still Yawn is in a good
position
feels like a small victory for both of
them right with this ending of this game
and the way it's gone for Yan he keeps
his one point Victory F1 point lead with
just three games remaining and for ding
on the other hand a survival with black
without having to sweat it too much
definitely the energy is required and he
can focus on his game with the white
pieces and Fabi in a 14-game match
it feels as if the weight of each of
these games is very different and the
closer we get to the Finish Line the
closer we can see that the match is
about to end the pressure rises in each
of these games even if it's a level
match which was the case in yours and
magnus's World Championship is it true
that as the match gets closer to the
Finish Line the tension Rises what's at
stake feels a lot more and this might
impact decisions
yeah certainly what's at stake I mean
each game becomes more critical because
we come to the point where a loss you
might not be able to recover from
especially in Dick's position right he
already been done the match but you know
if we're going into last game then
like my last game against Magnus you
know he he certainly could have played
on he had a much better position the
final position but he uh didn't want to
take that risk uh even if it was a very
minimal risk that you know things go
wrong and you can't recover from a loss
so he uh he decided to take the decision
to basically just make a draw instead
and yeah players might tend to rock up a
bit at the end of the match especially
if they're in the lead that's totally
normal
I think also Jan made a general
correction in his play
in terms of uh like super practicality
because we we know that for a long time
Jan as strong as he was suffered a bit
from moments of uh
weakness which just really shouldn't
happen in in practices results very
negatively for example uh going all out
for a win in certain positions or just
making uh blunders that are
uncharacteristic of him because he was
rushing decisions and now we see a
player who's basically a super practical
professional we saw them the candidates
we see that in this match as well now
he's taking very very uh practical
decisions trying to keep the game
controlled at any cost pretty much
I think ding is happy because well we
see with the
speed that he's making these moves it
almost seems like he's excited uh
that he he was able to
defend a slightly worse position without
any sort of suffering
you know he's so confidently making
these moves now it feels like
it feels like he's happy that Dion took
on C4 you know this this game is headed
for draw and the players are now
blitzing out the final moves
although
it looks like Jan is still going to keep
a pawn advantage
are you because E3 Falls as well but
King F2
and Rook C5
and then the king runs to H3 and we get
a drawn position where white is a pawn
up so for example
King F2
um black is not obligated to take only
three but let's say he does I think F2
Rook to A3 Rook to C5
Pawn can't be defended so some checks
King G3 Rook yeah king of three rookie
three King G4 okay two King H3 only
place to hide I guess G3
and let's say
I actually like the idea of tying The
Rook tying the king to H2 by playing
Rook A2
5 I was gonna do the same thing yeah
okay yeah yeah same same idea and white
king is completely tied to defense and
for example rookie seven cutting the
king off black can play I think H6 very
nice little move preparing king cafe
and the King cannot advance
uh so E5 I guess I don't know what else
King f8 rookie six King F7 or rookies
yeah you can play two against one again
uh which
which we we might see King G7 rookie six
kf7 yeah this kind of thing is very
lucky I think he'll take on E3 and and
we'll see this sort of
sort of end game happen which is you
know basically just a drone
Yep looks pretty forced I'm I don't
really see many Alternatives here I
guess black could try to keep this Pawn
saying you're two pawns are as good as
my one but this line is very forcing the
what we went down there isn't much in
terms of deviation for uh Yana palmchi
so I think ding Loren's just working it
out to his conclusion and he'll play the
forcing draw
yeah the reason I don't like oh sorry
Tanya I was gonna say it's amazing that
you found this idea where actually Yan
can still be up upon that the E5 Pawn
Falls but at the end of it with the King
pursuing White's Rook on E5 and that
weakness on e4 it looks like it might
not be a pawn that's gonna survive too
long and also there is a 40 move no draw
of a rule here so the players still have
to find a way to continue playing and
they can't offer a job so either
repetition or just keep on liquidating
the position but it looks like it's
likely headed towards the liquidation
and we might be seeing it to us as one
on the king side uh and probably really
nice idea because the first thought was
that it's an immediate draw it's an
immediate end that white black just
picks up the E3 pawn and the materials
equal but it's not it's not as it meets
the eye and that's always the case with
chess it's just not over till it's over
yeah absolutely and I'm gonna make a
prediction another king versus King bear
King's ends his game
because yeah they can't overdraw I don't
think that they're going to repeat
because you know why they stop upon so
maybe they'll just uh go all the way to
the finish line
nice well probably because you're in the
mood for making predictions I'm going to
use this as my opportunity to ask you to
make a harder prediction than the one
that you just did and Robert I want you
in on this and chat as well and my
question is and I'm going to start with
Robert on this one will we see a tie
break in this world championship match
what's your prediction
wow so since you're you're asking me do
I think Janda Palm she will lose a game
in one of the final three I
I think the odds are heavily in John's
favor I know two whites in the last
three games for dingley Ren a great
opportunities for him but the way Jan
has been playing I mean he really seems
to have that fortitude necessary to
convert this lead in the match into a
world championship title so I'm going to
say that we will not see tie breaks I do
think John de palmshi uh with his lead I
think he'll be able to keep it but now
that I say that watch dingley run win
the next game
and we might
your repetition here or Yan might decide
to step up with the King and we might
anyway see the game end in a draw Fabi
your turn Robert says that Ian has of
course the one point lead and he
believes and he expects Jan to take it
through with that what about you Fabi
well last World Championship Match we
had this uh prediction contest I'm not
even sure who who ends up winning that
prediction contest but at some point
because we didn't want to uh you know
keep predicting draws or like predict
the kind of obvious uh obvious results
we were sort of making some wild
predictions like Jana's gonna win with
black against Magnus and uh which is of
course is not a very likely thing in a
single game so even though the odds are
definitely in eon's favor that he wins
without needing the playoff uh yeah
let's let's predict the playoff let's go
for it hmm
I don't know what chat has to say I'm
gonna go with Bobby on this one I would
love to see this match go down to the
wire simply because we've seen such
fighting chests from both of them thing
lyrin has a tough task for that he has
to win one of the next three games of
course the odds are stacked against him
but we've seen ding when it matters he's
managed to strike back in the match can
you do it one more time would love to
see this go down to the wire would love
a playoff in this Robert uh but right
now that task is a Monumental one for
ding it's not going to be easy getting
there yeah I think every fan of the game
except for young the Palm she fans would
like to see a tie break that's always a
lot of fun uh but yeah just the way Jan
has been playing I mean yesterday's game
more so this game is to me is kind of a
nothing game Jana's just coasting with
this one as Bobby was saying if it's
earlier in the match he would not have
traded all the pieces off he would have
tried to work that Advantage but look at
him he's sipping on his tee he's
enjoying himself he's like I have a lead
what do I have to worry about my
preparation with black yesterday was
stellar and he doesn't have just
preparation for this match let's not
forget he has a ton of preparation a
treasure Trove of preparation from the
candidates two of them that he won from
the world championship in 2021 against
Magnus uh Fabi let me ask you this how
long did you have leftover preparation
for
uh I think only a few months only a few
months
right after that I right after the match
I played in London and I was able to use
some of the prep that we had against uh
against Levon
and I played a match against Levin and
the prep was actually kind of really
important for winning that match against
Levon
um because I used one idea with white
against the Berlin which ended up
winning a rapid game and I used some
prep with black twice to to make
comfortable draws with the black pieces
against him so yeah I'll immediately
after the prep was was extremely
valuable and then I played a match
against Hari Krishna in February wrapped
in Blitz match and a lot of the prep
there was used a lot of the Petrov prep
and that was also very important for
that match against Hari so
but then after that it eventually became
kind of just yeah kind of dissipated
like I showed most of my ideas
uh chess evolves very quickly so I would
say three four months after that it was
basically uh yeah equal footing with
with the other guys
but I would say these days if you
prepare for world championship match
because technology has increased so much
and you can find you can quickly find so
many ideas that if you're given like
months and months to prepare you can
really uncover a lot of very interesting
stuff that it might last longer and
after his his first uh world
championship match against Magnus I feel
like young was very well prepared
uh for
like the rapid and Blitz tournaments
that he played uh for the next
candidates a lot of that Petrov prep it
was like very important that he had a
pretty unshakable repertoire with the
black pieces
so
hard to say I think that after this
match for for sure Yan will continue to
show very good results because of his
extremely good prep as well and and ding
as well I think will have plenty of
ideas and continue to show very good
results
he's shown some incredible ideas in this
match itself and his his ability to sort
of agree to play them and to go for a
new idea every day with pieces every
game with the black pieces has been
quite incredible to watch but there has
been this feeling that has it been in
depth has that preparation been in depth
or is it a trade-off that the more ideas
you have the more difficult it is to
sort of fight against and know every
single alternative that your opponent
might have and this one well it seems
like it's been a Flawless game by
dingler and with the black Pieces Just
making sure that everything was under
control
perhaps would have made more of his
chances after that commitment move of C4
but given the math situation has decided
to go into this end game which should
end in a draw and the position that we
have in front of us King to H3 has been
played Yan gets up leaves the board
tinglerin is trying to think what is the
most efficient way to end this game as
quickly as possible to give the least
amount of chances to Young right now and
the one thing that comes to my mind here
is is it time to already start marching
up with that King we were looking at
continuing to give checks and allowing
white to step up with that G3 Pawn but
can ding actually Force matters here
with a move like King F7 and try to go
King to F6 if you grab the E5 Pawn
yeah for sure it's uh definitely
definitely a viable way of playing and I
think
yeah ding is just thinking about the
most accurate way to make a drawing here
but
there's uh I think probably the only
losing moves are Rook A5 and Rook takes
G2 and everything else
even silly moves or rooksy too I forgot
about that one
so as Robert pointed out and even a
silly move like Rook to A8 maybe G5 is
also on the verge I don't know G5 Rook
rookie five is probably pretty fine
after H6 anyway
well you don't want to play G5 right I
mean that would be a risky Endeavor for
sure so we're at the point where we're
talking about the only moves that are
possible to lose this game which means
that dingley Wren will pretty
confidently hold the dribble I actually
like that he's slowed down he did this a
couple games ago when he had the black
pieces uh when he knew he could make a
draw he gave up a pawn so his Rook
Knight in two against Rook nine three
and he actually said in the post-mortem
right when he was talking about some of
the analysis oh I could have lost if I
made this move so he is trying to be
very precise he understands that this is
a draw but why should he Rush he's an
hour plus on his clock the best thing he
can do is make the draw how much time he
has left remaining is irrelevant so I
think that he is doing something that is
very educational for everybody at home
who thinks oh I have a draw in the bag
let me just make moves you should be
certain at this point and dingley rank
could probably visualize this to its
conclusion so I think as he makes the
move Rook to E2 it's just like the lines
we were talking about earlier he's going
to go after this e-pawn the white king
is very far away and won't be able to
get back into the game very easily so I
think this is just simple territory for
ding the rent who will bring his King up
to F6 yeah I think that this is just
very direct like Rook takes E5 King to
F7 just trying to get that epon back as
soon as possible
and King to G3 after that most likely
okay we'll probably see these boots
blitzed out king F7 King G3 King F6
rookie eight King f8
and yeah we might
just see it yeah we'll probably just see
all this
Center oh
nothing about the rest day and the next
game in their heads
yeah they know they both know this is a
draw but they know that why we'll get
two against one
[Laughter]
and will Yan return the favor by just
sacrificing the last pawn and then going
in a king versus King Bobby you
predicted that this game and will end
with the king versus King position
it could also repeat it it's kind of 50
50 at this point if they'll try to find
the way to a King
against king or if they'll just make a
repetition
which do you prefer is someone who you
know makes draws at the high level do
you prefer going to Bear Kings or to the
three-time repetition
uh I'm a bit of a perfectionist and it
feels like a really perfect way to to
end the game oh okay repetition
immediately no no rotation Rook at AJ
would have won that H7 Pawn
but none of that
so just to draw
everything to F7 and he comes back with
the Rook 35. at that time repetition we
will see the players call out for an
Orbiter to check that
as it's not allowed to offer a draw in
this position so the Orbiter would
usually come and ensure that in fact the
position has been repeated Thrice a
little awkward pause there between Yan
ending as they wait for the Arbiter to
arrive the game has ended in a draw
yeah it's funny they have to ask for
permission to make a draw when they're
very obviously in a position that is uh
drawn and there's the handshake it is a
split point which means Jana pomshi
keeps his one point advantage in this
match
it does and it also means Robert that
dingler and has only three games to
strike back now but he will get to
whites out of those three games he has
to maximize his chances and look at that
we see the players sign off the
chessboard uh that's fun that's
interesting I would love to get one of
the world championship chess boards with
the signatures of the players on it
super cool stuff there well both these
players have got something to be happy
about with the outcome of today's game
thing lyrin maintains his Striking
Distance trailing Point while Yana
pamushi with just three games left
inches towards steps One Step steps well
at least makes one step closer towards
that world championship title and now
England will start the next game with
the white pieces we see the Kings being
placed at the right Square which does
signal that the game has ended in a draw
and it was quite a peaceful one Robert
certainly was we saw an opening instead
of the Berlin in the Spanish year A6 was
played and this is some Mainline stuff
Knight it comes out to F6 White Castles
Bishop to E7 and D3 a calm approach Fabi
I mean you could take it from here buddy
but it felt like it was a pretty solid
Affair from the start but there was just
probably one or two critical moments
yeah here ding played B5 Bishop to B3
and D6 this was following where their
fifth game I believe it was and here I
in the earlier game Leon had played C3
but instead he played A3 in this move
one of the main lines uh of the
anti-marshallah Knight A5 Bishop A2 C5
uh still following a lot of theory
Knight C3 Bishop to E6 and here Eon
played Bishop G5 as we mentioned white
has other options but this is following
the general strategy of of trying to
eliminate that Knight and take advantage
of the D5 Square short Castle happened
Bishop takes F6 Bishop takes F6 Knight
to D5 white has a D5 Square
and here black played G6 to drop the
bishop back to G7
uh Queen D2 is the moment that Ding
started to think
and he played Bishop's G7
we were discussing if maybe Knight C6
was more accurate but certainly his move
cannot be a bad one
night to G5 was played
and here's C4
move which surprises a little bit we
were we were looking at other moves
right but
C4 is a very interesting one to block
off that Bishop on A2
Knight takes E6 fe6 Knight to E3
Bishop to H6 pinning that Knight to the
queen so the Knight cannot move and C4
is indirectly defended Rook a to D1 and
hear an excellent move that Tania
pointed out before and then was quickly
played by ding Rook to B8 now the move
which comes to mind immediately but
defending against any sort of detex C4
ideas by preparing The Rook on the open
file I would open up after d takes C4
and this is indeed what happened but
maybe this was Jan's chance to push a
bit more in the game with the move Queen
to E2 as we were discussing
white keep some certain Advantage
although uh not a tremendous one but
definitely something to play for
but Jan went straight for the most
concrete approach D takes E4
Knight takes C4 Bishop takes C4
he takes E4 all the pieces got traded
out very quickly after Queen takes D6
take trading on E3 trading on F1
trading on B2
and
very soon it was a rook end game with
neither aside having any serious winning
chances White's still gaining a pawn but
not enough to win the game as we saw
yeah and then we ended with a three-time
repetition where we were just joking do
you prefer bear Kings or a three-time
repetition what's your drug Choice chat
get involved let's know would you prefer
to make a draw by three-time repetition
or by being King versus King that's or
stalemate let's throw that in the mix
and let us know but either way this game
it didn't have as much life as some of
the others and that's because yonda
palmshi in that moment where he could
have played Queen D2 he decided let's
just trade all the pieces let's
liquidate let's make that draw get ready
to rest tomorrow before going into game
12.
hasn't lost
this game with white pieces in this
world championship match so far he keeps
that up to date not just today this is
he is a 20 game streak of not losing
with the white pieces and we will be
hearing from the players soon as they
get ready for the press conference
today's result today's game both these
players have got reasons to be pleased
with the outcome but once again the
pressure is on for danger clearly he has
a white coming up in the next game but
one gets the feeling and tell me guys if
you would agree with this that Ding is
definitely very relieved with that move
D takes E4 and just how easily not just
the result but just how little it took
out of him to draw today well we will
talk more on that but right now we can
see that the players are ready let's
head over to Astana to hear it from Ding
and Yan
laughs
hello everyone welcome at the press
conference of round 11. today the game
has ended in a draw and the current
score is
65 in favor of Jana publishing uh I
would like to ask
both the similar question the same
question in fact
first I'll go with ding the first moves
into this game were similar to the one
you played at the candidates tournament
back in 2020 which was won by Jana
pomichi does this past result influence
today's game from a psychological point
of view
yeah when I when he played A3 I recorded
game
this was a very bad memory for me he
didn't
push very hard to win with this line but
why it's always maintain some small
advantages and
black belt to be careful to Health but
today he you know we played another
line in this in inspiration
and I guess I my prayer was much better
than last time
what about
you um sorry Yan
do you want me to repeat the question
maybe oh no no no not really I can I can
slightly recall the question uh so uh
yeah I mean uh there is
um this uh A3 D3
Lopez is always like slight pressure
polite and I guess
um
yeah yeah we had this game in um
but uh I think yeah today uh Dean played
a different uh different line yeah this
early
95 C5 I mean basically all lines are
very good you can say free and
everywhere white is like a very small
pressure
um I'm not I'm not quite sure I was I
was right to just to take on C4 because
of how I thought that I will at least
get this free against two Rook end game
uh but uh yeah unfortunately free
against two never never happens so like
like has enough enough time to to make
sure like it's
uh I might want to get an extra Pawn so
yeah probably this was a little bit
premature but anyway I think yeah black
is very solid so yeah perhaps should
have played it slowly like I don't know
Queen into maybe instead of uh DJ C4
yeah so this was
perhaps not the best decision but anyway
I don't think it was something very
serious for it
okay
um I think was there today's game
any real chances to spice up a little
bit the position and to play for a
decisive result
if so or do you think you could have
deviates in order to get more active
game
well after 95
at that point I play C4 and yes after C4
he always have
the chance to legalize to the end game
but instead of C4 if I play anything
else then F4 comes I will be in
Danger
of getting worse
so I don't think I have so many chance
today
right and and also I'll just follow up
with the next question
there are still three games to go in
which you will have two whites is there
anything you will change in your
strategy to maximize your chances to uh
to get the victory unit
of course I'll try my best in the last
three games
also tomorrow we'll be interesting I
have more time to prepare some extra
ideas
think that the most difficult part of
the match
is already behind and now you just have
to finish the job or you do think that's
the most critical games are still ahead
of you you gotta be kidding
sorry you got to be kidding no I'm not I
mean indeed like it's it's free games
and like
I should I should give it earlier to
uh to to do the job let's say so but of
course like it's
nothing like anything like
uh like it's over obviously not it's
pretty
pretty much in clear match I think
okay thank you and my last question to
ding
um
anyway do we have questions in the Press
I would like to go first with your
questions yes please yeah
and the question is that today it's a
draw on the one hand it's a draw on the
other hand uh your one point ahead and
this gets you closer to the end result
are you satisfied with the results of
the game today
um
foreign
[Music]
I can't say that I'm fully satisfied
with the result of the game I think that
D7 was not the um greatest decision
um after uh before there are plenty of
chances but night support was also a
working decision and the draw is still a
draw that gets me
close to to the end result so thank you
do we have more we have questions from
leoncho please
as I don't have too much to write about
today's game I will kindly ask you your
help to write about some different topic
but connected with which are the
preventive anti-cheating measures taken
by feeder in this world championship I
have two questions for both of you the
first one is are you satisfied with
those measures or do you have any
suggestion to improve from that sense
and the second question making clear
that I'm not asking you about concrete
names is do you think that
any of the world's top 25 have ever
cheated
um thank you for the question Janu will
go first with you oh thank you for the
question uh it's
uh I guess it's three It's tricky
questions especially the second one
so yeah I guess in the cycle tournaments
like same was I guess in Madrid and uh
in the candidates in the previous match
I guess
I mean
one wouldn't believe this is possible
yes so I mean all the measures are being
taken quite seriously and also you sort
of like trust your opponent whom you
know so well uh but speaking of uh I
don't know some top players
I mean you can never be sure especially
when you play online
uh uh but uh I mean open the war maybe
over the board mainly out of the board I
I could I would hardly believe
uh but there is always
I mean there is always
someone who speculates about this yes so
once again I guess
uh it's very difficult to like
completely like
like uh prevent it like so there would
be no like zero chance yeah to um to
play unfair but uh uh I hope that you
know uh the risk of uh you know
denunciation is to to Hype for uh
especially for the top players to
um to do this
thank you I think what about you well as
we know there are some changing cases
happen online but over the board
especially for the tournament I have
already played I have played I don't
believe there is some cheating happens
at the same time
thanks a lot to both of you thank you
very much next question please uh I have
a question to Dean uh then you are down
one point did you have any ideas of
playing I don't know Sicilian or maybe
some sharp line to get back to the fight
because you played E5 today and maybe
it's to calm or maybe it's too early for
you to take a lot of risk yes still it's
I I think it's too early to play
something like Sicilian at that point
still there are three games ahead you
know in candidates I I win on the last
game so
anything can happen in the last three
rounds
thank you thank you very much next
question please
talk from this side in Hamburg a
question to both players have you heard
that 500 meters from here
um Hans niman is playing in an open
tournament do you know about that and
what do you think about that
uh
yeah actually
I heard there is like a quite quite a
strong open tournament yeah and I think
I checked
I checked the starting the list of
players
but uh
still I don't get your question
uh no not really
what about you I think
well actually I didn't follow the
tournament he prayed
uh so which tournament did he play
side events of the match alongside
Kazakhstan cup that's the event yes
okay it says a lot uh do we have more
questions from the Press
I don't see any more questions okay
please
a question to Jan
um there are not too many uh games left
and today there was a fourth draw do you
intend to have any more Force draws in
the upcoming games
thank you for the question
um with the black pieces I definitely
wouldn't say no to a fourth draw
um and today there it wasn't my goal to
have a quick game with the fourth draw I
did not use my advantage
um in the game and
yeah I don't know I do not intend to get
both draws on a plane
thank you very much uh
time for
they will bring the question from the
audience which are asking the questions
on Twitter
thank you Katie my name is Jesse
February my first question is for ding
from Margaret could you discuss the
general ideas after C4 and the possible
imbalances since it took 13 minutes to
play this move
well we're not at mad 95 the idea was
on take on E6 or play F4 then take on
essays and Knight attacks on my phone so
we'll see for at first I cut his Bishop
and yeah that's basically the whole
point behind sifo
the next question is from Amit for both
of you if you were to propose challenges
or changes rather to the World Chess
Championship Match format what would you
suggest so if you were to change the
format
of the match or would you suggest yeah
and we will go first with you
yeah good question but
for a moment I actually I don't care
what about you think
well no I think the tournament can be
even longer you want to have more rounds
yeah
okay would they be classical round
classical rounds yeah
thank you fair enough next question
please my last question is a little
unrelated to the match for nepo are you
still following DotA do you make time
for gaming these days
thank you for the question we are
sometimes I follow but I almost like
stopped playing and surely okay
there is
no like no free time here to
uh to play one or two games here but uh
yeah when it's
like after the measure perhaps yeah I'll
I'll play a little bit yeah for now it's
not the best idea there was one more
related to DOTA what is your MMR
uh before it was higher than now
all right thanks
thank you very much
um I see that there is no more questions
in the Press I don't have more questions
as well tomorrow will be the rest day
for the players the match will resume on
26th of April I wish the players to have
a good rest day tomorrow thank you very
much
[Applause]
thing wants more classical games as only
three remain understandable from his
perspective it would mean more
opportunities to come back to the match
more opportunities to take bigger risks
currently the margin for erading Keeps
declining with every single game gone
and four back-to-back draws means that
janapanushi ends game 11 with a one
point lead he's on Six Points Yan is one
and a half points away from becoming
world champion things task is cut he
starts Game 12 with the white pieces he
will have two whites in the final three
games he has to maximize his chances he
was alluding to using the rest day as
perhaps coming up with a new idea before
we got into that I want to ask you do
you want more classical games in this
world championship match
if they're not like the game today then
definitely
but I I can understand things uh things
feelings yeah if you're trailing the
match the only amount of games you want
is at least one more at least one more
chance to get back into the match and
I'm sure we'll see that he'll have some
chances he'll have a rest day now to
prepare his opening you know I'm I'm
sort of out of predictions for what that
opening may be because maybe ding
doesn't even know at the moment maybe he
still needs to the rest day to decide on
what first movie even he that he wants
to play
yeah and for dingley Ren I mean of
course he wants more games what does he
want to take us back to the karpov
Kasparov match where carpa was up five
uh games to none but his first to six
wins then Kasparov came back and then
finally they had to stop the match
because the players lost so much weight
and were so exhausted but of course we
understand ding's perspective and for
Jan I actually like that he got to
answer that DOTA question at the end
because it did seem to bring him some
happiness some Joy whereas mostly other
questions he just shook off was like I'm
not talking about any of that stuff I'm
just focused on this match so it's good
to see Yan still enjoying things still
enjoying games outside of Chess and he
clearly was happy to receive that one
question but probably none of the others
do you think he played any daughter
during the rest there Robert
oh he said he's got no time for anything
but chess here uh but he probably will
play once this event comes to its close
he hopefully is world champion you know
from his point of view uh when he gets
to play DotA next but uh yeah he's not
playing anything but chess during this
world championship
I'm logging the express conferences and
these uh I'm finding the answer is
extremely amusing and the players I feel
that along the way they've sort of
learned how to handle tricky questions
now we saw ding also mentioned that how
he felt that the situation was not
desperate enough for excessive risk
today and that he still has two whites
coming up but the path to come back is
getting narrow now we're just three
games there will be a point Fabi where
he will have to take maximum risk
to be honest I think it's already uh the
next game maybe not maximum risk but he
should be viewing that game pretty much
as a must win maybe not a complete must
win but you don't want to let it all
ride on that last game you know with the
white pieces where you we might estimate
the chances that someone beats Eon on a
specific one one game with the white
pieces as you know maybe 10 uh you don't
want to have that 10 chance maybe even
less than that you know on just one day
so he has two chances I think that each
game he should be viewing uh two Chances
with the white pieces one with the black
pieces but that's not really a chance
you can count on so much I think every
game he should be viewing as uh any
small chance I need to try to maximize
it and I should be trying to create as
many problems for my opponent from the
start of the game as possible
I don't envy his position it's a
difficult one but uh he may be up to the
task
he did allude to the candidates where in
fact it was the very last game that he
won defeating Hikaru Nakamura finish
that
here playing The Limited match Robert do
you agree with the Fabi here that
despite there being three games he needs
to maximize his chance in every single
one of them and the time to take risks
has indeed arrived oh for sure because
even that wind over Hikaru I mean that
couldn't have been expected a car was
playing great chess uh winning a chess
game at the highest level uh sometimes
it feels like it's nearly impossible so
I think that dingley red he needs to be
better prepared than he was uh yesterday
because he got caught in the opening he
was surprised he needs to be well
prepared and play something combative at
some point you just have to go all in
and it's maybe not necessarily all in
just yet but it does start to feel that
way I think that Bobby's right that the
next game he really needs to fight
Tuesday that is tomorrow and then that
will be followed by Game 12 and game 13.
we see there on Saturday will be the
final game of the World Championship
match a standalone game it will be in
Game 12 and in game 14 that dingler and
will play with the white pieces he does
have tomorrow's rest to focus on the
opening the biggest problems that he can
perhaps try to pose to Jana Pam Nishi we
are expecting a huge opening there by
ding coming out of that rest day he did
allude to looking at some fresh ideas
having that possibility of the rest day
to try to surprise janafamishi one more
time it's going to be an exciting day
and before we close Fabi I'm gonna open
the floor to you just for your final
thoughts on the action that we saw today
yeah it was a it was probably the most
quiet game that we've seen in the entire
match you know we saw a relatively quiet
game the day before but still some
problems in the end game we were
speculating about you know is is Zion in
trouble in send game is he is he gonna
hold it and it was it was close to being
an unpleasant end game although he
played excellently but today once they
reached the end game there was no
question to anyone's mind that this game
is heading to a draw there was only one
moment in the game that I can point to
where maybe on could have uh played on a
little bit more or put more pressure on
his opponent and in fact Jan also
mentioned that in the press conference
the move Queen to E2 instead of D takes
E4 he said maybe this was the way to put
some pressure on ding
but it would have been exciting I I wish
we had seen that and seen what would
have happened in case of that it would
have been an exciting game instead D
takes C4 it looks like the players
really needed a rest day needed you know
a little bit of a break from all the
action that we've been seeing these past
few weeks in this incredibly exciting
match back and forth games and now a
little bit more of a quiet period but
the last few games I'm sure will not be
quiet because ding has to win at least
one of them
he really does and once again the path
gets narrower and narrower a dingler and
is one point behind Jana pamushi it was
a confident hold by doing today with the
black pieces and he will be coming back
with the white pieces in game 12.
tomorrow is a rest day Robert Fabi thank
you so much for all your amazing
insights and chat a huge shout out to
you for also being there and making this
show so much fun with all your featured
chats we will be back with the action
for game 12. tomorrow is a rest day and
we leave you right now with all the fun
that we had in game 11.
Jana is playing this also super
confident since G5 not a single move has
he thought for more than like 10 seconds
I think every move has been just bashed
out instantly I don't think that they
will take too long to play this one out
dangly red he knows what he needs to do
today and that is not loose I'm
expecting the jackets to come off first
moves are about to happen the blocks
have started one E4
one to make with dingler in what will he
start with will he reach out for C5 no
he goes with E5 the king spawn opening
Fabi you look disappointed a little bit
C4 a big move but a very committed one
and look at Jan he's got that pose that
we saw from him back in game nine where
he feels that perhaps he's got a bit of
a chance here to try to create something
at this moment for dingler and if he was
to lose a game that would be essentially
World Championship over so it's very
important for doing more important than
creating chances is to make sure that
he's able to keep things under control
Robert you you called it this is the d
word we're heading for a draw there's
the handshake it is a split point which
means Jana Palm she keeps his one point
advantage in this match
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]